The Shining has attracted an almost
cult-like collective of fans who long to
discover its secrets what follows are
our favorite fan theories we've gathered
up from internet forums fan films and
documentaries like room 237 and just
putting the movie on repeat until we
start coming up with our own kooky
headcanons of all the theories out there
about the true meaning of the shining
one of the more plausible ones is that
the film is an allegorical tale about
the genocide of Native Americans by
white settlers the most overt hint
occurs when Stuart almond a smiling
white guy who dresses in red white and
blue and has an American flag on his
desk casually mentions that the Overlook
is literally built over dead Native
Americans the site is supposed to be
located on an Indian burial ground and I
believe they actually had to repeal a
few Indian attacks as they were building
it throughout the hotel are depictions
of Native Americans and Native American
art motifs such as the enormous sand
painting on the wall of the Colorado
lounge Jack even uses the phrase white
man's burden in a conversation with
Lloyd a reference to a poem by Rudyard
Kipling that valorizes the colonization
of natives by white imperialists
internet film scholar Kevin MacLeod who
did a commentary track for the home
video release of the documentary room
237 also claims that the film features a
pair of hidden symbols from another
group of indigenous Americans the Maya
he asserts that in the iconic bright
yellow film poster for the shining the
extra-wide letter T in the title is
actually a Mayan symbol and that a
repeating pattern in the carpet of the
Gold Room across within a square is
actually the symbol for yellow there are
also a handful of strange but compelling
parallels between the film and the
real-life founding of Point Pleasant
West Virginia this was a horrific bloody
event with countless Native American
casualties but perhaps the most famous
native person killed there was Ho Kola
[ __ ] also known as chief cornstalk in
1777 Kokkola [ __ ] was killed by a mob
seeking revenge for an attack that he'd
had no part of and of course legend
states that ho colas was final words
were a curse on the land that would
leave it quote paralyzed by the stain of
our blood there are two things I knew
about white people they loved Rachael
Ray and they are terrible
of curses this statement has clear
parallels to the famous wave of blood
from the film but believe it or not it's
not the biggest link between the Battle
of Point Pleasant and the shining in
1909 the same year the fictional
Overlook Hotel was completed in the film
a real-life monument in Point Pleasant
was struck by lightning and the same
thing happened again on July 4th 1921 as
any true shining fan knows July 4th 1921
is the date on the old photograph of
Jack from the final shot of the film
before we go any further let's get one
thing straight
the moon landing wasn't faked
Mythbusters did a whole episode about it
go watch hidden figures educate yourself
however there has been a conspiracy
theory circulating since before the
shining came out that the Apollo 11 moon
landing was faked and that Stanley
Kubrick was the one hired by the
government to shoot it it would
obviously be nearly impossible to carry
a secret like that without letting it
out somewhere so could the shining
actually be Kubrick's covert confession
I don't think that's true well no but
let's run down the conspiracies favorite
evidence there's Tang in the Overlook
pantry a product popularized through its
association with the space program in
one scene Danny is wearing a handmade
sweater famously depicting Apollo 11 and
the Saturn 5 rocket also during the
adaptation from the book to the film the
most haunted room in the hotel changed
room numbers from 217 to 237 and
according to shining conspiracy
theorists the distance to the moon is
about two hundred thirty-seven thousand
miles away in truth it's more like two
hundred thirty eight thousand nine
hundred miles away on average but we
didn't know this until the late 60s
maybe COO trick was looking at an old
textbook without a date information when
he and NASA were trying to fool the
entire world by faking the most
documented news story of all time this
could be intentional though by 1980
Kubrick was most likely aware of the
conspiracy theory since it sprung up
after he directed 2001 a Space Odyssey
in 1968 and he also knew how closely
people analyzed his films for hidden
meanings maybe he decided to just mess
with them a little for fun we all know
what happens when it's all work and no
play
one of the most subtly haunting elements
of the Overlook Hotel is that it's
layout constantly seems to be shifting
the bright exterior window in Allman's
office is completely nonsensical because
his office is in the middle of the
building and during a conversation
between Wendy and Jack in the Colorado
lounge a chair in the background keeps
appearing and disappearing again between
shots and when Halloran is giving a tour
to Wendy and Danny they step into one
giant freezer but then exit from a
different freezer across the room
Kubrick was a notoriously meticulous
filmmaker so it seems unlikely that
these strange occurrences are just
mistakes what else might they signify
maybe the Overlook isn't actually the
Overlook at all instead it's held where
Jack must continually repeat the last
winter of his life forever it's not that
big of a stretch as we already know the
hotel has at least one other imprisoned
killer ghost in the form of Grady
sometimes doesn't seem to remember
killing his family with this reading
many of the film's more puzzling lines
suddenly become meaningful like Jack
having an odd familiarity with the
Overlook before he even arrives and I
came that period for my interview as
though I'd been him later
Grady tells him that he's always been
the caretaker and maybe that eternity if
the hotel is his reward for the sins of
his life remember unlike Wendy and Danny
Jack is only ever seen in the Overlook
or on the road that leads up to it
whenever you're watching The Shining
Jack is always the caretaker there are a
lot of continuity errors and
geographical oddities in the shining but
maybe that's because Jack and his family
are hallucinating throughout their stay
at the Overlook in fact maybe they're
the subject of a government-run science
experiment according to this theory
Jack's employment of the Overlook is a
front so that the US government can test
out mind-control techniques on isolated
test subjects and all the supernatural
visions the Torrance's experienced are
actually the results of these
experiments it's a fun theory but
there's not much evidence to back it up
apart from a single incongruous poster
in the game room it's an image of a
skier above the word monarch which is
the first time Danny sees the Grady
girls in the hotel however during Jack's
interview Ullman claims that there's no
skiing in the air
so why would they advertise it in the
game room and what is monarch well it's
actually monarch Mountain a ski resort
that's been open in Colorado since 1939
but according to conspiracy theorists
monarch was the name of a real world CIA
project that attempted to discover the
secrets of mind control in this reading
of the film the character Bill Watson
who seems like Stuart almonds assistant
is actually the brains of the operation
a high-ranking government agent notice
that Watson is called in to almonds
office when Jack arrives and yet he
doesn't get a job title and he doesn't
ask Jack any questions in fact he
doesn't have any dialogue at all other
than a blunt hi
later on he just sits there watching as
almond tells Jack about Brady in the
over looks creepy history planting those
ideas in Jack's head later when almond
tells Watson to transport some luggage
Watson almost seems annoyed like he's
not used to taking orders and when all
then gives jacket or Watson trails
behind watching everything and saying
nothing one unusual interpretation of
the shining is that it's less of an
adaptation of Stephen King's novel and
actually a modern-day retelling of the
ancient Greek myth of Theseus and the
Minotaur
just like the labyrinth that houses the
Minotaur in the myth the Overlook has
its hedge maze where the movie hits its
climax as Jack chases him Danny escapes
the maze by retracing his steps just as
Theseus escapes the labyrinth by
following back a ball of twine that he'd
been unwinding as he walked could this
be a second meaning to the sign outside
the gold room that advertises the
unwinding hours at several points in the
film Jack stares into the distance with
a lowered head but with eyes pointed up
in the classic Kubrick's tear apart some
theorists even cite the monarch poster
in the game room which again is for a
real-life ski resort you can go to
because the skier is a silhouette with
strange proportions it's a stretch but
the mythical Minotaur was the descendant
of a royal bloodline which leads to
another
oddly convincing connection in the
original story the Minotaur was the
product of a union between a human and a
beast and well the audience and Wendy
definitely see something along those
disturbing lines something is up with
this movie and mirrors Danny's first
vision occurs in front
mirror jack recognizes the woman he's
kissing in room 237 is a corpse by
looking into a mirror there's a long
scene of Jack talking to Wendy that
takes place entirely in a reflection
Danny's creepy Redrum graffiti can only
be read correctly when mirrored the grey
girls are mirror images of each other
the film even opens with a shot of a
reflective lake mirroring the scenery
above it
perhaps the Overlook itself is a mirror
in that it's only torturing guests with
the evil that they bring with them that
would explain why Jack an alcoholic with
a history of abusing his son was
corrupted by the hotel while Danny and
Wendy were not whether it's the true
meaning of the movie or not the use of
mirrors is definitely an intentional
illustration of one of the shining
steeper themes the idea of finding truth
through looking backwards through
history or looking into mirrors occurs
all throughout the movie from the reveal
of Redrum as a terrifying warning to
Dani escaping his father in the hedge
maze by retracing his steps by looking
backwards
Danny avoids becoming a victim like the
Grady children the idea of finding truth
by turning backwards has led to some
fans to try playing two projections of
The Shining on the same screen at the
same time one playing forwards and one
playing backwards to see if this finally
reveals the movies many secrets it might
not have led to any deeper truths but it
has created some awesomely creepy
imagery then again maybe this movie is
the real mirror and these fan theories
say more about us than they do about the
film not all shining theories are deadly
serious or profoundly deep and some of
them are so wild that they're worth
talking about for just how weird they
are for example writer and journalist
Mary Katharine ham has a theory that the
story of The Shining has been retold
more recently as Disney's frozen before
the story begins our tortured
protagonist has a dark chapter in their
past that looms over their present where
they inadvertently injured in an
innocent young family member then that
volatile character is put in charge of
running a big castle in the snowy
mountains meanwhile their innocent young
family member is locked out of a
forbidden room and passes the time by
playing with toys in the hallway and
when things go bad a wide-eyed cheerful
character with prominent teeth tries to
protect them eventually the pressure
this new job causes our darkened
tortured protagonists to snap and turn
against their family the family is in
over their heads so it's up to an
experienced expert at navigating the
snowy wastes to climb aboard their
faithful mount to come to their rescue
in the end both movies end with a
character getting frozen in one case
it's temporary and in another it's
permanent but you have to admit that
while everything might not line up
there's enough there to have some goofy
fun with it's a weird ridiculous and
truly wild theory but for some reason we
just can't let it go check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]